it's official sam worthington does still
make movies but does he make good ones
[Music]
man on the ledge that's right sam
worthington is a man on a Ledge a jumper
which can only mean one thing he has
seen nine out of ten of his movies and
so by that this could be a really cool
movie like phone booth you know where
it's just like one guy in one situation
and negotiators but something else is
kind of going on that puts that guy on
that ledge but it's isolated to this one
incident it could be really cool dead
it's just not I won't spoil too much for
you even though the trailer absolutely
does but I'm gonna tell you a little bit
of what's going on just a little bit
don't worry spoiler free zone here still
first of all we have Sam Worthington on
this leg which is great because you know
his agent was like oh dude what can I
put him in at all you know someone was
like oh hey sam worthington agent i got
a job for your boy okay he's gonna be a
man on a Ledge he gets to be on a Ledge
the entire time don't even think he has
to do much that's perfect and everyone
was happy and this movie proves the
point that you already knew which is Sam
Worthington has no range whatsoever he
is just that guy his roles are the same
in every movie they're interchangeable
there's nothing it's just the same thing
every time
it's response to every question could
just be I'm gonna do what I do and then
I'm gonna stop him every time that's his
line his vibe his everything and well
this ledge thing is going down there is
also a heist going on yeah yeah a heist
I'm not going to tell you the who what
when where why I have the highest other
than there is a heist going on which now
it rests on is this a cool heist movie
no it's not it's just generic as it gets
one thing that got me in this whole
heist situation other than going yeah
that wouldn't work oh yeah that wouldn't
work either if you're gonna make kind of
a high-techy heist movie at least make
it logical that these scenarios are
gonna work out the sidekick in this
heist is this absurdly hot chick that
you've never heard of all right now you
know me you know I'm never gonna
complain about a hot chick being in a
movie usually I like me the eye candy
it's all good it's a nice bonus to
watching a movie but first and foremost
the concern should be the character and
the actor who can make the character
work this character is in there just so
they can have a hot chick in this movie
she's not even good at what she does
she's just a hot chick in this movie why
not have someone who's good at hi sting
things really hot though which makes me
think the producer this movie was like
oh hey but I have this really hot chick
because I'm rich and I can get hot
chicks like that she really wants to be
in a movie so yeah we're gonna put her
in this movie it won't make sense but
we'll make it work and in the end of
this movie when it all wraps up there's
one thing in particular where you're
like that I don't I'm not buying it
that's as simple as that I'm not buying
it it's not it's not like you
walk out of this movie going this is the
worst piece of I've ever seen if I
had a time machine I would go back in
time and not get lottery numbers I would
stop myself from watching this movie
instead you just kind of walk out look
at your friend and go no well maybe you
don't know what you're talking about
Worthington I'm gonna say this movie
it's alright but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus one day yep
forgot about it already I mean there are
moments where you're like okay that's
kind of cool all right I'm liking that
it would be a really good straight to TV
movie or straight to DVD or something
instead it gets a theatrical release in
which you're gonna have to pay 10 bucks
a ticket to see it no way here's a good
question what is your favorite Sam
Worthington movie that's the question
this time around whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more I'm gonna do what I do I guess you
better stop there
[Music]
you